so going into happy death day i really
didn't have any expectations i kind of
wanted to see if i can enjoy the movie
it'll be entertaining and it was it was
a very entertaining movie
it has its flaws clearly and you could
see that coming in the trailers but for
the most part i enjoyed it lead actress
jessica roth as trey
did really well here i thought she was
great and it was really impressive
reacting because this is a story about a
girl who goes from being
a real
bad person in a sense and that classic
sorority girl that has like no morals
anymore and something bad's in their
past and she plays into someone who's
very likable so props to her and i like
to take that the more messed up her life
got the better of a person she became
it's almost like that kind of forced her
to change herself and all the stuff she
was taking for granted and not raising
all the people she's hurting by running
away from her problems and making all
this was making her face her problem so
i really like that part of the story
there was some really more bad writing
here and that's not the story per se but
more of the lines
and it really was in the beginning when
there's certain scenes i was like people
talk like that like when trey our main
character
sees the creepy stalker dude who's
really good looking for a stalker and
says you took me to subway on a first
date but unfortunately you didn't have a
footlong
bad line just leave that one out and
then my real big problem with the
writing was when the roommate
spoilers haven't seen the movie we find
out is the killer but there was a big
hint when you first meet her and trey
asked her
hey how did you know it was my birthday
and she says oh i looked at your
driver's license who does that who would
look at the roommate's driver's license
and go oh it's their birthday the odds
of that
this creepy weird thing to look in their
wallet like that i didn't like that that
gave away to me that she was
maybe not the killer but in on it in
this whole groundhog day effect and then
there was a real cheese this is all on
the first day by the way we see
all this cheesy writing that was kind of
there when we find out
that trey is getting with the professor
and they're hooking up and he's like
it's not dudes right now i have patience
and she's like but i'm losing mine and
the kisser is like again not necessary
line you can write that a little better
but as we go on i thought the movie got
better especially the day two of the
story when she wakes up again it was
kind of cool to see how she'd react now
to realizing what was happening and
there's a lot of funny humor in this day
specifically but in the movie in general
the funny part's hit especially when
she's getting murdered and one of those
random frat guys just walks in hammered
and just is like whoo and then walks out
the crowd i was with
was dying laughing in the part so that
really hit well and then day three when
she wakes up i really like when she
wakes up more intense it really amped
everything up and everything's her
vision's blurry it was really cool
camera effect and she's seeing
everything and she's like having a
meltdown and she starts opening up a
little bit to other people about what's
going on but then my big problem of a
sequence here
was day four when she wakes up and she's
already made this plan now she's gonna
find out who this murder is and she
wakes up and they play that song don't
you say i'm complicated
took me out of the tone of the movie
didn't fit and it became a teeny bopper
movie all of a sudden when it wasn't
like that in the beginning all of a
sudden i get there going for that
audience but it did not feel right to me
and it was just like why this is really
solid right now this movie why i do this
whole sequence of her putting the shades
on acting confident really took me out
of believing the story and buying
that she would behave a certain way in
this scenario we're all saying yeah i've
been murdered three four times i've no
idea what's going on i'm having a
nightmare but now i'm super confident
and there's poppy songs in my head it
was like give me a break that was
annoying that was too mainstream movie
for me real corny and then especially
when she has the military gear on she's
trying to scope out people that you
think might be on her hit list of who
could be after her that whole sequence
was awful to me horrendous
but i'm happy the whole movie wasn't
like that it recovered well because then
when it gets back to the serious tone
and more grounded out of that sequence i
still was really interested to see who
the killer was the acting was still
really solid to me and there's still
some really good humor here for me i
like when she was more of not the
i'm confident i'm gonna get the killer
it was more of like when she was just
like accepting what was happening and
not giving a crap
especially i thought it was really funny
when she was at the diner and she let
out that fart i thought that was
brilliant that made me chuckle pretty
hard because as a guy
you almost want to see people be that
loose well maybe it's not like i want to
see girls fart but you want to see
people that loose and not so protective
all the time what was great about this
movie was showing a girl getting rid of
that mask and that shield and being
herself more and more which i really
liked and then they trick you and make
you think the actual murderer is a guy
who looks just like tom york from
radiohead i mean look at the
similarities it's literally the same
dude i thought it was him started
laughing at that and then i didn't know
how i felt about it just being someone
who was some random murderer who's
killed other women and she found it on
the news so i was like all right i
thought it'd be a cool reveal but that
might be where a huge problem was here
where
once we found that out i really liked
how she
that day planning to get this guy now
the right way and kill him
she made amends with everybody she was a
good person she was your genuine self
and it had a really good lesson about
putting down these barriers and running
away from your problems and facing them
and being a good person how it makes you
feel better and while it was going
through that sequence and she sees her
dad and she apologizes and opens up
about her mother i like that because i
do know a lot of girls and guys at our
age in our 20s just getting out of
college or still in college where a lot
of people try to like
just avoid their problems and not talk
about things and everyone's so
masked and uptight and afraid to be
themselves just had a really good lesson
here a really good message and i did not
expect that in a movie like this but i
really enjoyed it but then i thought the
movie was going to end at that and then
she wakes up again and it wasn't the
killer and then i thought this was a
little too much and it almost felt like
we just saw a bunch of deleted scenes or
an alternate ending thrown onto this
movie where the roommate is revealed to
be the killer who originally thought it
was from her saying she looked at her
driver's license which didn't make sense
and she had the cupcake with one candle
and then it got way over the top and
then she pushes roommate at the window
and it's a crime scene where she lives
but they don't really investigate into
her pushing her roommate out the window
even though she did the right thing but
it just didn't make any sense that she
just go hang out with the guy she likes
and he invites her back to her place
after she just literally killed somebody
very odd and that was just not necessary
to make any sense wasn't realistic i get
the movie's not realistic because it's a
groundhog day effect but come on i want
to still buy how someone react to it and
that was asking a lot so i felt like
that whole ending with the roommate
reveal you got to pick one it's going to
be the roommate or this tom your killer
pick one they already pick a timer kill
then they do the other ending it just
felt like two endings in one too much
and it worked better if you just stuck
with the roommate or just stuck with the
killer as tom york but overall i really
enjoyed this movie and if you're gonna
see this movie or if you already saw it
obviously you gotta accept it for what
it is and just go for the ride it's
entertaining it works so what it's
trying to do has its flaws but overall i
was impressed and i enjoyed it so i'm
gonna give it a i was thinking 7.5 but
that double ending annoyed me so i'm
gonna give it a seven
but really good acting here and jessica
roth showed me the main girl
huge potential to be a star so
really held down this movie a lot for me
it's a tough role to play you gotta
think about it if she's filming those
scenes and there's no music actually
playing behind her she's carrying all
this and she's in scenes with this
murderer has no dialogue and the
transformation of her character
throughout she did really well she timed
it perfectly to how it would react to
getting it almost seemed like a complete
rejuvenated person so props to her on
giving death day seven is your first
time seeing me please come back for more
reviews i do movies tv shows celebrity
interviews trailer reactions please
subscribe comment below what you thought
of this movie i respond to everybody
really want to know if you agree with me
disagree with me any thoughts you have
in the movie at all let me have it and
keep coming back